[Music]
after a one-day weather delay
spacex is scheduled to launch four
astronauts to the international space
station tomorrow morning
here is a live look at launch pad 39a at
the kennedy space center in florida
the mission is get is set to make
history mark strassman is near the
launch pad
to tell us why mark good morning
good morning anthony let me show you
something that's never been seen before
on a rocket that's about to launch
astronauts take a look at the bottom of
the rocket that black stuff covering the
first stage that is
soot which means that this rocket has
flown before
and that's not all so has the capsule
that the four astronauts will be riding
inside
it's the first time that both will be
reused to fly
people another milestone for a company
that's already
revolutionizing space travel
[Music]
there once was a time when splashdown
meant a museum
for a crude space capsule not anymore
welcome back to planet earth and thanks
for flying spacex
this dragon capsule charred like a
marshmallow
flew spacex's first crew last summer now
with a new heat shield and parachutes
spacex is set to fly people in it again
its next passengers this international
crew of veteran astronauts
including two americans
spacex will also reuse the first stage
booster of this rocket
from its last crude flight in november
by landing and re-flying its boosters
spacex has driven down the cost of
launching satellites and cargo
but flying people on used hardware
required nasa's okay
and so we went through a pretty
exhaustive process with spacex to look
at what we needed to refurbish on those
systems
and go on to engineering to make sure
they're safe to fly at least it did the
job that he was designed for once and
everything worked fine the first time
around
tomorrow's crew is confident the
hardware will work
just as well the second time around i
think you have to be
an optimist if you're going to be an
astronaut if you think at everything
that could go wrong
it's a rather long list and you're not
going to sleep much at night
release this was nasa astronaut megan
macarthur
working on the hubble telescope back in
2009
her confidence returning to space
tomorrow in a used capsule
runs deep i know somebody that i trust
completely
was was really involved in developing
this vehicle that
somebody is fellow astronaut bob benkin
her husband on that very first spacex
flight last summer
benkin flew in the same crew dragon
capsule in fact
sat in the very same seat that his wife
will ride into space
it is funny to me that sometimes i'll
start asking questions of the trainers
and they'll say you know your husband
had this same set of questions for us
is he going to leave you a note i'm not
sure although i think you know if
there's any chewed up gum under the seat
i'll know where it came from
the weather forecast is looking good for
liftoff tomorrow set for 5 49
eastern time 5 49 in the morning the
crew will
dock with the space station gail on
saturday morning
that is very cool thank you very much
mark we all remember when her husband
went up
that's right i love that they're
thinking alike when she says you know
your husband asks the exact same
question
i like that one i just love the whole
thing they keep talking about the used
hardware though yeah i know
there may actually be gum under the seat
yeah but it still flies they clearly
know what they're doing
we are certainly cheering them on